the Hiroshima atomic bomb Dome and peace
Memorial Park is no stranger to visitors
but many people here have not heard
about the Blockbuster film about the
Mastermind behind the atomic bomb that
destroyed Hiroshima and Nagasaki in
1945.
[Music]
the Distributors of Oppenheimer have yet
to decide a release date for the film in
the country that saw hundreds of
thousands of people die in the blacks
and 78 years later sensitivities remain
at the end of the day they're still
victims and bereaved families around so
I think it's possible for the film not
to be shown out of consideration for
those people's feelings
I think that among others there'll be
plenty of people who wouldn't want to
see it I think there are a lot of people
like debris families who would be
critical and wouldn't agree with showing
it
foreign
the film has been criticized for not
showing the devastation that was caused
by J Robert oppenheimer's invention
although some people say there is value
in showing the movie to a Japanese
audience to better understand an
American perspective I think people are
still interested in the film maybe
interested in the American perspective
of all of this I think maybe it might be
even better to show it here and then
call it educate Japanese people even
more about it you are the man who gave
them the power to destroy themselves
and the world is not prepared when
moviegoers in Japan finally get a chance
to watch Christopher Nolan's latest Epic
it may renew the debate about the human
cost of the events that ended World War
II
Truman needs to know what's next imrano
lahan Al Jazeera
foreign